until France reached the latter stages
of this tournament the French public had
been somewhat ambivalent about this
world cup but reaching the final is
special and across France the excitement
and anticipation was intense as the game
got underway the first half saw France
rocked on their Heels by Argentina's
ruthless intensity and at half time
France was two nil down and the fans
were reeling we don't have the ball and
we cannot really do anything so I don't
I think it will be very hard in the
second half but I still have hope in a
win of course hope turned to something
more confident in the second half by now
those without seats stood those without
space peered through the windows with
barely 10 minutes left the French fans
were sent Delirious by two quick-fire
goals from Star Striker Killian mbappe
the game now level at two all
into the second period of extra time
nail-biting tension again gripped the
supporters Messi put Argentina ahead but
with just two minutes left on the clock
and Bape again sent the supporters into
convulsions of Joy This World Cup final
had become a genuine classic
but that left penalties and for the
French it was to be heartbreak the
roller coaster ride was finished
I feel sad because obviously I'm French
but that was the best game I've ever
seen and I'm pretty happy for Argentina
because they lost in 2014 and they are
great great teams I feel uh very well
because I have two nationalities I am a
Argentina and uh France also emotions
it was a huge factors in the shadow of
the Arctic Triumph Victory had Slipped
Away
so the party is over for the French and
here at the Champs Elise where the party
would have been held had they won there
is no party at all these few stragglers
over my shoulder now making their way
home in a rather miserable France
drizzle it's a disappointment for a team
which came into this tournament with
such high expectations but they came up
against the magic of Messi Paul Brennan
Al Jazeera Paris